continue talking about your health
cancer doesn't stop even in the middle
of a pandemic
two doctors in the valley have created a
new program the first of its kind in
nevada
that focuses on rectal cancer here's
more information
welcome to the show dr boyer and dr
barticholu
thank you much so let's first start off
by
introducing yourselves and your
specialties to everyone
sure i'm dr barbara i'm a i'm an
associate professor of surgery with unlv
medicine
and i'm the chief of colorectal surgery
so primarily
i'm treating patients with their
surgical
surgical treatment this mom dr boyer i'm
a radiation oncologist with genesis
genesis care
formerly known as 21st century oncology
and i've just come to the las vegas area
about
a year and a half ago after spending 24
years in the united states army
most of which as a radiation oncologist
tell us some of the issues that we're
facing in regards to
rectal cancer we think about a cancer
such as rectal cancer
it becomes really complex because so
many specialties um are really needed to
treat
a patient again we're talking about
surgery chemotherapy
radiation treatment and it all adds up
so that is really the complexity to
tackle a cancer
this complex and um through a lot of
research it's been established that the
care
is lacking in a lot of areas throughout
the united states
so first was a little bit of gathering
data but then
and all the national leaders decided to
to do something about it so
the next step is to say all right we're
going to really go through
come up with criteria how to make it
better
and then build up programs and it's an
official national program
the accreditation program for rectal
cancer by the american college of
surgeons
how do you think this program can
actually change lives in regards to
rectal cancer
well i think this program being
accredited by the american college of
surgeons patients aren't going to have
to leave las vegas
to get the best care for the rectal
cancer they can stay right here
they'll get the care that's on par with
that they would get in los
angeles san francisco phoenix and more
so it really offers the patient
state-of-the-art cancer care
so it's not only going to lead to
improved outcomes for patients but i
think they'll have a better quality of
life for it
with the pandemic going on what's your
advice dr boyer to people who are
at higher risk for rectal cancer but the
bottom line with rectal cancer and with
all cancers
the earlier the better so while we do
see a light at the end of the tunnel
with these vaccines that hopefully will
be starting soon
i you must absolutely must not delay
your cancer screenings
all cancers are better treated the
earlier they're
and if you did to detect a cancer early
perhaps you can be
cured with surgery alone and you won't
need radiation therapy or chemotherapy
but the longer you wait the more
advanced the cancer gets and the more
therapy and
the less our chances of curing you and
or the more toxic
therapy will be for more information and
to find locations near you
call genesiscare the number is right
there on your screen or visit
genesiscare.com las vegas now we'll be
right back